Intro
We may all try to stay polite in our day to
day lives for survival, if nothing else, but
when we go to the movies, there's nothing
more satisfying than seeing the bad guy get
what's coming to him.
But a good movie hero doesn't need bullets
or explosions to reduce their enemies to ash:
sometimes, all it takes is a brutal insult.
Whether the audience is left just as stunned,
laughing in their seats, or quoting the same
slams for the rest of their lives, crafting
a truly crushing one-liner is an artform,
not a science.
That's a fact proven with our look at 20 Movies
With The Most Savage Insults of All Time.
Anchorman
Whether you're on live television, or insulting
a loved one, Ron Burgundy knows the answer
is always saying the first thing that comes
to mind - but be prepared to take some shots
in return.
Or if you're Brick Tamland, just make sure
you sell a half-baked insult with a condescending
smile (and friend to back you up).
Gran Torino
In Gran Torino, Clint Eastwood seems to do
more damage with his mouth, than with his
automatic weapons:
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
It's the movie that helped get Robert Downey
Jr. back into the spotlight, but it's co-star
Val Kilmer who dishes out the best insults.
The Mist
Who says a Stephen King horror movie can't
find room for one of the simplest, rudest
digs from the person you'd least expect it?
Knocked Up
We usually expect that rudest mood swings
from the pregnant character, but this stream
of insults on the outside of a velvet rope
works no matter who's saying it.
Good Will Hunting
It's not easy to use a goofy pun to crush
somebody into dust, but Matt Damon found a
way with one of the most quoted digs ever
delivered in a Boston accent.
Snatch
Does an insult need to make sense to put the
fear of God into someone?
This line from Guy Ritchie puts the idea to
the test.
Gangs of New York
Daniel Day-Lewis wins an Oscar almost every
time he disappears into a role.
But as "Bill The Butcher," every time he spoke
his mind was an award in itself.
Christmas Vacation
Clark W. Griswold has a famous temper, but
it took the holidays to truly push him over
the edge, using his words like every father
should aspire to.
Glengarry Glenross
Almost every sentence out of Al Pacino's mouth
sounds like a one-liner, but in Glengarry
Glenross, he turned insults into an artform.
Uncle Buck
John Candy isn't known for a harsh temper,
but most of us were too young to appreciate
the brutal insult from Uncle Buck.
As Good As It Gets
Playing a famous author, Jack Nicholson showed
why his character couldn't tell the difference
between being clever, and insulting half the
population of Earth.
Blade Trinity
Long before the Merc With the Mouth, Ryan
Reynolds was taking on vampires with Blade's
help - and delivering dozens of Deadpool-worthy
lines along the way.
Con Air
Even murderers have their limits - but if
you really want to insult a fellow inmate,
get as disgusting and relatable as possible:
"For me, you're somewhere between a cockroach
and that white stuff that accumulates at the
corner of your mouth when you're really thirsty."
Clueless
Hardened criminals or foul-mouthed men don't
have anything on the teenage girls in this
classic, with lines that still make us wince.
Home Alone
Sometimes, an insult is just for the audience
to enjoy - and repeat to themselves, and their
friends, for the rest of their lives.
Bull Durham
There are classic insults, and then there
are the ones we'll never be able to deliver
like the stars - but we can dream, Mr. Costner.
Ghostbusters
Two heads are better than one, and if duo
dissing was an Olympic sport, there's no question
Bill Murray and Dan Akroyd take home the gold.
The Departed
You can insult people by disrespecting all
they stand for, or just by being clever.
But if you're Mark Wahlberg, why not do both
at the same time?
Wayne's World
Garth may not get much credit for his brains,
but Wayne's World saw him deliver one of the
most polished movie metaphors we've ever heard.
Deadpool
Deadpool is one anti hero who is not afraid
to shoot you in the head - or cut down some
of the most well-known X-Men with some truly
choice words: "If I ever decide to become
a crime-fighting shit swizzler, who rooms
with a bunch of other little whiners at Neverland
Mansion with some creepy, old, bald, Heaven’s
Gate-looking motherfucker… on that day,
I’ll send your shiny, happy ass a friend
request."
Those are some of our favorite one-liners
and crushing insults that put movie villains
in their place, but which are your favorites?
Should a truly great movie insult be impossible
not to recite among friends, or are the best
too good to ever imitate?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!